but it doesn't feel like
you've created a character and then a
prosthetics thrown on top of it it feels
like you have studied this prosthetic
and and
grew into the body that you then have or
or the face that you then have i'd love
to hear a little bit of your um
how you go about that
yeah uh the uh the process is all of the
above
i i have to do all of the
work that an actor has to do with uh
you know all the information we get from
the script with the writer's intention
for that character his wants needs loves
uh fears all those things and how i
interact with other characters then when
you add a fantastical look to it that
brings a whole other element of
information in for what this character
is where he comes from
uh so
and and
even playing human beings you have to
play the character from head to toe i
believe so that would take on you take
on a new posture and a new gesturing
system with every every human you play
so add to that uh some animal instincts
or some alien instincts or things that
you have to infuse into this
and the look helps inform a lot of that
uh you know especially if i rehearse if
i if i if i read a script and think oh
this character is going to be doing this
with his arms above his head the entire
movie and they get the suit on and it's
like this is all you can do what do you
have to kind of alter
what you have you know rehearsed or
thought in your mind so so it very much
is a
a a community
that has to come together to create this
character uh and i'm just a part of it
[Music]
and hold me back all through the night
you're shining bright i'm your oyster
baby you're my pearl